Charles Schwab war Anfang des letzten Jahrhunderts
einer der reichsten Menschen der Welt. Aber
nicht weil er viel Geld geerbt hatte. Sondern
weil er als einfacher Angestellter Stufe für
Stufe die Karriereleiter nach oben kletterte,
bis er in seinen dreißigern Präsident von
Bethlehem Steel wurde, dem damals zweitgrößten
Stahlproduzenten der Welt. Aber wer gibt sich
schon mit Platz 2 zufrieden?
Schwab wollte deshalb seine Mitarbeiter zu
noch besseren Leistung motivieren. Aber nicht
durch längere Arbeitszeiten, sondern durch
mehr Produktivität. Doppelt so viel erledigen
in der Hälfte der Zeit; das war sein Ziel.
Aber ohne fremde Hilfe war es unerreichbar.
Schwab vereinbarte deshalb ein Treffen mit
dem Unternehmensberater Ivy Lee. Und der meinte:
“Gut, ich kann Ihnen helfen. Dafür brauche
ich 15 Minuten mit jedem Ihrer Führungskräfte”.
Auf die Frage, wie viel das Kosten werde,
entgegnete Lee: “Gar nichts. Wir sprechen
uns einfach nochmal in 3 Monaten und dann
können Sie mir so viel Geld geben, wie Sie
für angemessen halten”.
Bemerkenswert: Lee wettete also darauf, dass
Schwab ihm freiwillig viel mehr Geld geben
würde, als er jemals für seine Dienstleistung
hätte verlangen können. Aber welche Produktivitäts-Technik,
könnte er denn den Führungskräften in 15
Minuten vermitteln, damit Schwab ihn aus Dankbarkeit
mit Geld überhäufen würde?
Nun genau das, die sogenannte Ivy-Lee-Methode
lernst du in diesem Video.
Zum besseren Verständnis brauchen wir davor
noch ein wenig Hintergrundwissen, was genau
uns eigentlich unproduktiv macht. Tatsächlich
sind das nur zwei Dinge:
Erstens: Prokrastination.
Statt einfach mit der Arbeit anzufangen, lenken
wir uns ab, indem wir Socken-Preise auf Amazon
vergleichen, im Kühlschrank nachschauen,
ob etwas neues dazu gekommen ist, seit wir
das letzte mal reingeschaut haben – vor
10 Minuten –, oder wir klicken uns durch
alle 1300 Facebook-Fotos eines Mitschüler,
mit dem wir nie wirklich befreundet waren.
Tja, was glaubst du, ist der Hauptgrund für
diese Prokrastination. Die meisten würden
vermutlich auf einen Mangel an Motivation,
Disziplin oder Willenskraft tippen. Aber interessanterweise
liegt die Ursache häufig woanders:
Wenn eine Aufgabe zu umfangreich oder zu groß
scheint – zum Beispiel einen Vortrag vorbereiten
oder eine Abschlussarbeit schreiben – dann
führt das zu Unsicherheit. Ich weiß einfach
nicht genau, wie ich anfangen soll. Und ich
bin unsicher, ob ich mich vielleicht blöd
anstelle und mich blamieren werde.
Um diese Unsicherheit zu vermeiden, wenden
wir uns dann häufig Dingen zu, die uns vertraut
sind, zum Beispiel YouTube-Videos schauen.
Das lenkt von den schweren und verantwortungsvollen
Pflichten ab. Aber nur weil wir den Kopf in
Sand stecken, verschwinden die Aufgaben dadurch
nicht, sondern werden im Gegenteil noch schlimmer
und eine Negativspirale beginnt.
Erstmal Anfangen ist also wichtiger als ein
perfektes Ergebnis. Wenn du produktiver als
andere arbeiten möchtest, musst du deshalb
Prokrastination in den Griff bekommen, sprich
alle diese Unsicherheiten reduzieren! Wie
das geht schauen wir uns gleich an.
Davor zum zweiten Punkt, der uns davon abhält,
in derselben Zeit mehr zu Schaffen: Ineffizientes
Arbeiten.
Wenn wir dann letztlich doch mal mit der Arbeit
angefangen haben – vielleicht weil die Deadline
auf einmal gefährlich nahe gekommen ist – schaffen
wir trotzdem lange nicht so viel, wie wir
eigentlich könnten.
Selbst wenn wir unsere Zeit maximal ausnutzen:
Neben dem Telefonieren E-Mails checken während
wir die To-Do-Liste umsortieren und außerdem
an einem Text feilen. Multitasking funktioniert
zwar grundsätzlich – offensichtlich können
wir verschiedene Dinge gleichzeitig tun, wie
Netflixen und Kochen – aber wir können
uns nicht auf zwei Dinge gleichzeitig konzentrieren.
Multifokus ist unmöglich! Wenn zwei Aufgaben
deine Konzentration beanspruchen, muss dein
Gehirn immer zwischen beiden hin und her springen.
Und das hat seinen Preis!
Wusstest du, dass wir im Schnitt alle 5 Minuten
unsere E-Mails kontrollieren und dann jedes
mal knapp über eine Minute brauchen, um uns
wieder voll auf die Hauptaufgabe zu konzentrieren?
Pro Arbeitstag vergeuden wir dadurch im Schnitt
1,5 Stunden alleine durch das ständige Kontrollieren
von Nachrichten. Und dazu kommen natürlich
noch andere Unterbrechungen, vielleicht wenn
jemand gerade etwas von dir braucht.
Es ist also unmöglich, in einer Aufgabe hervorragende
Leistungen zu bringen, wenn du deine Aufmerksamkeit
ständig zwischen zehn verschiedene Dingen
aufteilst. Um effizienter zu arbeiten, darfst
du dich also immer nur gleichzeitig auf eine
einzelne Sache fokussieren!
Und zwar auf die Sache, die wirklich wichtig
ist!
Wir tappen häufig in die Falle und glauben,
dass alle unsere Aufgaben, alle unsere Verantwortlichkeiten
essentiell sind. Und dadurch verzetteln wir
uns am Morgen in Kleinigkeiten, lesen kurz
noch eine Nachricht und tun dem Kollegen schnell
einen Gefallen.
Das fühlt sich vielleicht produktiv an, ist
es aber nicht. Am Ende des Tages sind so die
wirklich wichtigen Dinge mal wieder viel zu
kurz gekommen.
Wenn du zu viele Ideen hast oder von der schieren
Flut an Aufgaben überwältigt wirst, dann
helfen die Kernideen aus den folgenden beiden
Büchern:
Eat That Frog von Brian Tracy: Erledige die
unangenehmste und wichtigste Aufgabe des Tages
direkt als erstes. Sehr sinnvoll, denn je
länger der Tag dauert, desto mehr sinkt die
Konzentration, während die Anzahl an Ablenkungen
steigt.
Essentialism von Greg McKeown: Erlaube dir
selbst, dass du nicht immer zu Allem ja sagst.
Nur wenn du versuchst, nicht immer alles zu
tun, kannst du deinen besten Beitrag zu den
Dingen leisten, die wirklich wichtig sind.
Weniger aber besser ist hier das Motto.
Fassen wir mal kurz zusammen, was eine ideale
Produktivitäts-Technik erfüllen sollte.
Sie sollte Prokrastination reduzieren, indem
genau vorgibt, welche machbaren Aufgaben wann
abgearbeitet werden müssen. Sie sollte Ineffizienzen
vermeiden, indem sie Multifokus unterbindet
und stattdessen die wirklich essentiellen
Aufgaben priorisiert. Und insbesondere: Sie
sollte einfach genug sein, um in der Praxis
zu funktionieren. Und zwar nicht nur in den
ersten Tagen, während wir noch hoch motiviert
sind, sondern wirklich langfristig!
Wenn wir alle diese Punkte zusammenfügen,
kommt ziemlich genau die Ivy-Lee-Methode heraus.
Sie besteht aus 5 Schritten:
Erstens: Brainstormen.
Schreibe am Ende deines Arbeitstages die sechs
essentiellen Dinge auf, die du morgen unbedingt
erledigen willst. Achte darauf, große Projekte
in machbare Etappenziele aufzuteilen, die
du leicht an diesem Tag abschließen kannst.
Zweitens: Sortieren.
Ordne diese Aufgaben nach Wichtigkeit. Auf
Platz 1 gehört natürlich der Frog, die zentrale
Aufgabe, die du unbedingt erledigen musst.
Auf Platz 6 die am wenigsten wichtige Aufgabe,
für die du nicht mehr so viel Konzentration
benötigst. Dank dieser Liste weißt du am
nächsten Tag genau, was deine konkreten,
machbaren Pflichten sind und in welcher Reihe
sie abgearbeitet werden müssen. Dadurch vermeidest
du Unsicherheit und Prokrastination
Drittens: Umsetzen.
Wenn dein nächster Arbeitstag beginnt, dann
fange direkt mit deiner ersten Aufgabe an.
Nicht kurz Email checken, nicht kurz einen
Geburtstag auf Facebook nachschauen, sondern
direkt anfangen und die Aufgabe komplett abschließen,
bevor du dich um die nächste kümmerst. Dadurch
vermeidest du Multifokus und schaffst in der
gleichen Zeit mehr.
Es hilft übrigens enorm, alle Benachrichtigungen
auf stumm zu schalten, damit du nicht jede
fünf Minuten aus deiner Konzentration gerissen
wirst.
Viertens: Aufräumen.
Wenn du nicht alle sechs Aufgaben deiner Liste
erledigen konntest, ist das überhaupt kein
Problem. Schreibe am Ende des Tages einfach
die unerledigten Dinge auf deine Liste für
den nächsten Tag und fülle diese nach belieben
auf, bis du wieder maximal sechs Aufgaben
notiert hast.
Fünftes: Routine.
Wiederhole den gesamten Prozess an jedem Arbeitstag.
Klingt in der Theorie super, aber wie sieht
es in der Praxis aus?
Was hat die Methode denn Charles Schwab gebracht.
Nach drei Monaten stand ja das nächste Treffen
mit Ivy Lee an; der Tag an dem Schwab Ivy
Lee so viel zahlen sollte, wie er für angemessen
für das Ergebnis hielt. Aber konnte mit einer
so simplen Methode nach so kurzer Zeit überhaupt
schon ein Resultat zu sehen sein?
Und ja, tatsächlich! Schwab war so zufrieden
mit den Ergebnissen, dass er Lee einen Scheck
über 25.000 Dollar ausstellte. Eine stattliche
Summe, wenn man bedenkt, dass Ivy Lee nur
wenige Stunden beschäftigt war. Und noch
beeindruckender wird es, wenn man es in den
heutigen Wert umrechnet: etwa 400.000 Dollar!
So viel, wie viele Menschen nach 10 Jahren
Vollzeitarbeit nicht verdienen.
Daran kannst du in etwa abschätzen, wie gut
die Methode funktioniert. Schwab soll sogar
über Lees Technik gesagt haben, dass sie
der beste Rat war, den er je bekommen hat.
Ich bin übrigens schon seit langem Fan der
Ivy-Lee-Methode. Probier sie auch gerne mal
aus. Ist sehr simpel umzusetzen, braucht kaum
Zeit und sorgt für viel mehr Produktivität.
Aber wenn du jetzt lieber noch ein wenig prokrastinieren
möchtest, ist diese Playlist über Produktivität
genau das Richtige. Viel Spaß damit und bis
zum nächsten mal :)